l'activité de ce mercredi après midi au
collège giacometti est un peu
particulière après avoir formé les trois
équipes les 25 volontaires s'équipent
des gants des pinces et des sacs
recyclables bien entendu l'association
je respecte ma ville les a conviés à une
séance de ramassage de déchets
l'histoire de la planète mais n'en
consacre hub concerne beaucoup des
écoliers ils sont engagés
pas d écouler surtout les jeunes aussi
ils sont engagés dans la préservation de
l'environnement et aujourd'hui c'était
sur le la base du volontariat et ils
sont tous venus parce qu'ils avaient
envie de faire du bien à la planète et
c'est formidable bout de papier bâtons
de sucettes et emballage de bonbons
constituent l'essentiel de la récolte
dans la cour de récréation des jeunes
qui se montre sensible aux causes
environnementales tout ce qui est
écologie c'est plutôt important or avec
tout ce qui est réchauffement climatique
et où il faut qu'on commence à se bouger
et c'est alors même s'il faut commencer
par un petit bout autant commencer par
la suite on va continuer continuer
revenir devant dernier passage devant
l'établissement
les bâtons de sucettes se transforme en
déco de cigarettes avant un quizz pour
déterminer la longévité des déchets
avant leur dégradation suivie d'une
pause réconfort faut aider la planète
ah parce que si on fait pas maintenant
les choses bande qui le fera après sur
la base du volontariat
nous sommes passés avec trois élèves de
5e qui ont initié le projet dans les
classes nous avons pris cinq minutes pas
plus pour expliquer ce que c'était que
le wac inapte à dire aux élèves que nous
pouvions le faire à échelle locale et
cinq minutes ont suffi justement pour
recueillir 26 à 30 candidatures et sur
ses presque 30 candidatures quasiment à
peu près de 25 élèves étaient présents
ce jour les ramasseurs du jour vous
invitent à les rejoindre samedi pour
cette journée internationale du
ramassage de déchets